ever since i did long kiss good night
i've always thought that you know women
women who kick ass are like great
i like to watch it you know it's become
sort of
a normal thing now but you know back in
the day
uh it wasn't so much someone who's
beautiful
dangerous and lethal
always has an appeal
the thing about these female assassin
pictures
is that most of the
plots are very predictable what this has
i think which is different is there a
lot of twists and turns in the story
surprises for an audience
obviously a good cast with michael
keaton and sam jackson and maggie q and
it's sort of fun there's a kind of fun
element to the whole thing as well
[Music]
but it's really what got me was the plot
which is very intriguing i like the
characters too and i like that kind of
sense of humor because richard rover
very some great dialogue between the
characters nothing sounds like this in
the world
i almost given up old family how the
world did you you
you taught me how to find things that
didn't want to be found
you